the streets of yangon today
became a battlefield
the overwhelming anger of protesters met
with overwhelming force
from the military
you can hear the gunfire as
demonstrators shelter
these were real bullets and they took
multiple lives across myanmar
it was the bloodiest nastiest day in
three weeks of protests
a young boy has been shot and played and
i think that was that was probably one
of the first death
today he was shot and laid on the ground
in front of a school
it was shocking and horrific to see
that uh innocent civilians are treated
like
uh you know rabbits little rabbits or
just a little bird
on a hunting ground they had come out in
their thousands
all across the country unwilling to let
myanmar's young democracy
slip away the country has been in chaos
since the army seized power on the 1st
of february
alleging electoral fraud without giving
convincing evidence
last week the military leader said
authorities were using minimal force to
contain the protests
there was nothing minimal about today
this is a brutal response to a peaceful
protest
um the security forces were out
throughout myanmar
very early this morning they made it
very clear they
intended to uh attack people uh before
they had a chance to
amass in large numbers nonetheless
people did
and so we have a collision course here
of a military that is
um showing its willingness to ratchet up
its brutality
and we have a people that have shown
their absolute
determination
protesters are still rallying behind
aung sang the elected
government leader she has not been seen
in public
since she was detained by the military
and stands accused of illegally
importing walkie-talkies and violating
covert restrictions
her next court hearing is expected to be
held on monday
[Applause]
myanmar and the protesters filling her
streets are entering a new
much more dangerous phase tom cheshire
sky news